approximately thirty years ago when I
was in oncology at the Children's
Hospital in Philadelphia a father and a
son walked into my office and he both
had their right eye missing and as I
took the history it became apparent that
the father and the son had a rare form
of inherited eye tumor retinal blastoma
and the father knew that he had passed
that fate on to his son that moment
changed my life it propelled me to go on
and to co-lead a team that discovered
the first cancer susceptibility gene and
then the intervening decades since then
there have been literally a seismic
shift in our understanding what goes on
what genetic variations are sitting
behind various diseases in fact for
thousands of human traits a molecular
basis that's known for that and for
thousands of people every day there's
information that they gain about the
risk of going on to get this disease or
that disease at the same time if you ask
has that impacted the efficiency how
we've been able to develop drugs the
answer is not really if you look at the
costs of developing drugs how that's
done it basically hasn't budged that and
so it's as if we have the power to
diagnose yet not the power to fully
treat and they're too commonly given
reasons for why that happens one of them
is it's early days
we're just learning the words the
fragments the letters in the genetic
code we don't know how to read the
sentences we don't know how to follow
the narrative the other reason given is
that most of those changes are a loss of
function it's actually really hard to
develop drugs the restore function but
today I want us to step back and ask a
more fundamental question and ask
what happens if we're sort of thinking
about this maybe in the wrong context we
do a lot of studying of those who are
sick and building up long lists of
altered components but maybe if what
we're trying to do is to develop
therapies for prevention maybe what we
should be doing is studying those who
don't get sick maybe we should be
studying those that are well a vast
majority of those people are not
necessarily carrying a particular
genetic load or risk factor they're not
going to help us they're going to be
those individuals who are carrying a
potential future risk they're going to
go on to get some symptom that's not
what we're looking for what we're asking
and looking for is are there a very few
set of individuals who are actually
walking around with the risk that
normally would cause a disease but
something in them something hidden in
them is actually protective and keeping
them from exhibiting those symptoms if
you're going to do a study like that you
can imagine you'd like to look at lots
and lots of people we'd have to go and
have a pretty wide study and we realized
that actually one way to think of this
is let us look at adults who are over 40
years of age and let's make sure that we
look at those who are healthiest kids
they might have had individuals in their
families who had had a childhood disease
but not necessarily and let's go and
then screen those to find those who are
carrying genes for childhood diseases
now some of you I can see putting your
hands up going on a little odd how
what's your evidence that this could be
feasible I want to give you two examples
the first comes from San Francisco it
comes from the 1980s in the 1990s and
you may know the story where there were
individuals who had very high levels of
the virus HIV they went on to get AIDS
but there was a very small set of
individuals who also had very high
levels of HIV they didn't get AIDS and
astute clinicians so tracked that down
and what they found was they were
carrying mutations notice they were
carrying mutations
from birth that were protective that
we're protecting them from going on to
get AIDS you may also know that actually
a line of therapy has been coming along
based on that fact second example more
recent is elegant work done by Helen
Hobbs who said I'm going to look at
individuals who have very high lipid
levels and I'm going to try to find
those people with high lipid levels who
don't want to get heart disease and
again what she found was some of those
individuals had mutations that were
protective from birth they kept them
even though they had high lipid levels
and you can see this is an interesting
way of thinking about how you could
develop preventive therapies the project
that we're working on is called the
resilience project a search for
unexpected here because what we are
interested in doing is saying can we
find those rare individuals who might
have these hidden protective factors and
in some ways think of it as a decoder
ring a sort of resilience decoder ring
that we're going to try to build and
we've realized that we should do this in
a systematic way so we've said let's
take every single childhood inherited
disease let's take them all and let's
pull them back a little bit by those
that are known to have severe symptoms
for the parents the child those are on
the would know that they've gotten sick
and let's go ahead and then frame them
again by those parts of the genes where
we know that there is a particular
alteration that is known to be highly
penetrant to cause that disease who are
we going to look well we could look
locally that makes sense but we began to
think maybe we should look all over the
world maybe we should look not just here
but in remote places where there might
be a distinct genetic context there
might be environmental factors that
protect people and let's look at a
million individuals now the reason why
we think it's a good time to do that now
is in the last couple of years there's
been a remarkable plummeting in the cost
to do this type of analysis this type of
a data generation to where it actually
cost less to do the
a generation and analysis than it does
to do the sample processing in the
collection the other reason is that in
the last five years there have been
awesome tools things about network
biology systems biology that have come
up that allow us to think that maybe we
could decipher those positive outliers
and as we went around talking to
researchers and institutions and telling
them about our story something happened
they started saying this is interesting
I would be glad to join your effort I'd
be willing to participate and they
didn't say where's the MTA they didn't
say I'm where where is my authorship
they didn't say is this data going to be
mine am I going to own it they basically
said let's work on this in an open
crowd-sourced
team way to do this decoding six months
ago we locked down the screening Keith
for this decoder my co-lead a brilliant
scientist Eric shot at the icon Mount
Sinai School of Medicine in New York and
his team locked in that decoder key ring
and we began looking for samples because
what we realized is maybe we could just
go and look at some existing samples to
get some sense of feasibility maybe we
can take 2/3 percent of the project on
and see if it was there and so we
started asking people such as how can at
the Children's Hospital Philadelphia we
asked Lafe up in Finland we talked to
Anne Wojcicki at 23andme and Wang Jun at
BGI
and again something remarkable happened
they said ha not only do we have samples
but often we've analyzed them and we
would be glad to go into our naanum eyes
samples and see if we could find those
that you're looking for and instead of
being 20 or 30,000 last month we passed
1/2 million samples that we've already
analyzed so you must be going oh so you
must be going huh did you find any
unexpected heroes and the answer is we
didn't find one or two we found dozens
of these strong candidate unexpected
hereis so we think that the time is now
to launch the beta phase of this project
and actually start getting prospective
individuals basically all we need is
information we need a swab of DNA and a
willingness to say what's inside me I'm
willing to be reconnected most of us
spend our lives when it comes to health
and disease acting as if we're warriors
we delegate the responsibility for the
understanding of our disease for the
treatment of our disease to anointed
experts in order for us to get this
project to work we need individuals to
step up in a different role and to be
engaged to realize this dream this open
crowd-sourced project to find those
unexpected heroes to evolve from the
current concepts of resources
constraints to design those preventive
therapies and to extend it beyond
childhood diseases to go all the way up
to ways where we could look at
Alzheimer's or Parkinson's we're gonna
need us to be looking inside ourselves
and asking what are our roles what are
our genes and looking within ourselves
for information we used to say we should
go to the outside to experts and to be
willing to share that with others thank
you very much
[Applause]